[Music]
the Four Seasons Inn is located in West
Dover in Vermont's beautiful Green
Mountains former construction worker
Sandy McDougall purchased the Inn which
has 14 bedrooms an adjacent kennel as
the combination of a lifelong dream
since I was a kid I've always wanted to
own an in I always wanted to be able to
please people and give them a happy
experience
they smell really does me in a little
bit yeah
her hair was found oh what a dog hair a
dog hair impossible
this is a dream come true it's a
beautiful Inn
it's a great place it's a little slice
to have it I don't know what kind of
stain that is but I don't want to lay in
it I thought it was after only two years
Sandy Slice of Heaven has turned into
hell and you know why the fronts are not
working it's been nothing but
hemorrhaging money its bedrooms are
almost always empty and despite
marketing itself as a dog-friendly Hotel
the kennel lies unused Carol standing
into the end Cash Wise 1.15 million
dollars
out of my
butt it's terrific I'm glad I was able
to help with that Richard's my marketing
director I should be beating the hell
out of him every day because he sucks
Richard what's up with no money coming
in the in survives with just a skeleton
crew who live in the Inn for free
instead of receiving a salary and then a
drink I don't get paid so it's not
really a job it's more volunteering
go to the college
she said where's my money I want my
money I'm not getting paid I hit rock
bottom as of this morning I'm officially
maxed out on three cards and 14 in my
bank account I'll get the door Sandy is
generally a nice guy but staff does not
get paid
it's terrible there's endless complaints
about everything kind of reminds me of
the nursing home I worked at why we get
paid the big dollar [__] you Steve
Sandy's almost enemy is Sandy why the
hell is the grill on
Sunday's best friend is his dog Layla
who lives with him at the Inn Layla is
an English Setter she's the greeter so
come in the dining room she'll sit at
your feet
the guests complain about dog hair
everywhere and it makes them feel
disgusting dogs have hair dogs have
dander dogs drool I mean dogs lick their
own butt you don't want them anywhere
around the kitchen
most days there are more rooms occupied
by the staff than guests and if things
don't turn around soon this dog friendly
Inn will have to be put to sleep Sandy's
ragged
beaten we all are
If corn can't save this place four
seasons in is proper [__] I can't let
this hotel
he's running out of time he's running
out of money and he's running out of
energy this is the death rattle this is
it good God I can't be that screwed up
am I
this is exciting I'm back in Vermont
heading towards the Four Seasons Inn
trust me I've stayed in a lot of crappy
hotels and I'm finally getting to stay
in something Sumptuous and amazing the
Four Seasons in I've stayed at Four
Seasons all over the world they're
fabulous hotels that Define luxury so
this week should be a dream
hello
oh gosh well I certainly didn't look
like a full season to me
hello I was hoping for a dream but this
place looks like another nightmare
how are you Garden my first name is
Gordon know what my name is thank you my
name is Sandy receptionist call in sick
no she is around I will take care of
that for you okay great happy to uh
check in we have 18 rooms in the end the
rooms are beautiful
what a [__] mess I see that'd be mate
I'm surprised I'm still standing after I
open that door I swear to God I thought
I was going to [__] myself do you have a
room is that ready yes I do thank you
sir
[Music]
hey a bit late for the old party
Sandy hello
really the one room they don't make up
Aaron yeah
Ron I am pissed off room four is done
everybody go up and check it's just no
excuse for not getting the rooms done on
a timely fashion
this is my worst nightmare
Sunday
Sandy oh hello how are you yeah brother
I was shown to the honeymoon suites
I've lost Saturday it's a bit bizarre
Sandy is very scared of his his guests
because he doesn't like when people like
talk down about you know his Inn or his
food and stuff like that so he ties in
the kitchen he showed me into the room
it wasn't made and yeah yeah we were
kind of in the middle of doing all of
them what'd you do I'm the massage
therapist here and I do hula
constructing and also just say that
again the hula hoop instructing wow yeah
and obviously a huge amount of a month
for hula hoop dancers right not at all
here in Vermont but I don't know I kind
of picked it up but I liked it so
um you got another room for me yes I
live okay great good hoop instructor wow
[__] me that's the first
ah at least the bed's mate
thank God for that thank you wow this
wallpaper um it's uh it's eye-catching
right it came with the place right
[Music]
um I have to be honest I mean I've been
very fortunate enough to stay in lots of
Four Seasons but I haven't seen one
quite like this how long have you been
Affiliated uh we're not affiliated where
the Four Seasons in
oh so you're not full seasons where the
Four Seasons in
but you're not Four Seasons no no
affiliation
can you get away with that legally yep
do they call themselves The Four Seasons
where are the four seasons in
it's incredible and next month is going
to be the Waldorf Astoria Lodge no no no
no
um well I'm going to uh unpack thank you
sir
[__] me
uh Four Seasons yeah more like four
shades of [__] wow
[Music]
I've just found out that the Four
Seasons in is about as far away from a
luxury hotel as you can get
I need to find out what's really going
on here
how are you I'm good so how long have
you been here
five months I came here to do like
massage therapy and stuff but then we
didn't have like a really call for it
because it was slow so I just started
housekeeping do you ever stay here
I do oh you do yeah I live here
how does that work uh salary wise I mean
I don't get one
what do you mean don't get one I've
never gotten a paycheck you're joking no
so you're kind of scared to ask him
about it I'm not too Wicked excited
about not getting a paycheck but I don't
have a full-on conversation with Sandy
about it because I am scared that he's
going to yell at me and I just don't
want to take it God so how can you treat
this place professionally if you're not
getting paid you can't really I guess
treat it you can't no yeah bloody hell
yeah
no one gets paid what embarrassment take
it out
I can't believe Sandy doesn't pay his
housekeeper oh God no wonder my room was
such a mess I hope the food here is
better than the rooms
it's lonely in here
where the hell is everybody
hello hello
my name's Gwen Greg nice to see you
where'd you pop out of I popped out of
the kitchen
gonna get you started with a glass of
water here
that's Layla she kind of runs the house
here if you haven't met her yet yeah she
seems busier than the owner
entrees I'll have the mushroom ravioli
sounds delicious let's go for the salmon
as well after that cook with apples
finish with maple glaze and a Apple
risotto and you would like that or
risotto okay great all right
she's replacing an order line them up
I'm so nervous I'm trying not to puke I
puked last night before service and uh
after service and I'll probably do the
same tonight Apple risotto with the sand
and salmon seared not cooked through you
got
some bread for you
what do you think yeah disgusting it's
just so heavy and doughy
oh
Curry bread
nearly anything
Gordon did not approve of the curry
bread
oh Lord Sandy being a business owner
with no culinary experience or training
in any way that's what I was saying last
night it's doughy I don't feel that he
should be back in the kitchen working
later
[__] oh [__]
stay with me girl Sunny Curry bread
I'm having these next couple dishes are
at least
as of all
send it flavor
flavor I'm sure there's going to be a
lot of flavor here I have mushroom
ravioli
the dog just threw up on my plate I hope
not
wow
[Music]
how is it
um
are the passes undercooked
thank you
to saw thank you sorry no it's not your
fault
what's the main problems with this place
um management I mean the management is
Sandy right yeah I've worked for him and
haven't received checks
staff have worked hard for not being
paid yeah wow
jeez that's tough Sandy can be extremely
hard to work with and for bizarre
and weird
good God can this get any worse
undercooked okay all food in-house right
now that is coming off of this menu none
of it is local
none of it is fresh Sandy's menu is
garbage
am I right Richard oh Richard I'm sorry
first time we met and Richard you're not
a customer what'd you do I work with
Sandy on ideas for marketing what was
the last big idea you put into the Four
Seasons last big idea we had was
purchasing lift tickets at a discounted
rate right I would have fired you five
months ago coming into the summer what's
the next big plan and I can present
plenty of plenty of ideas but he has to
accept them I'm frustrated I feel that
the ideas I bring to him are helpful
they would work but Sandy he's just not
listening and here is your salmon
excellent thank you my daddy enjoy thank
you thank you
good God I hope it's at least halfway
good
and that is a Apple risotto
wow
what a punish [__] that sums it up on
that plate there he's as good as Chef as
he's an Innkeeper
[__] useless I can't believe I've not
seen Sandy once through my whole meal
what sort of Innkeeper ignores these
guess and hides in the kitchen well if
you won't come to me
just give me that knife now
hi guys hi I'm Steve Dixon Steve good to
see you bud Bill good to see you too bud
I'm trying to get a grasp on what I've
just eaten I know you're the owner yes
but you're the head chef as well as
we're working together now in town
so you're both head chefs I've I'm
I I I'm not I'm not exactly sure where I
fit in it it's not my menu I'm not doing
any ordering filled with Sandy right now
a little thrown under the bus I feel a
little betrayed right now
the risotto was sweet with what's in
there apple juice apple concentrate Chef
apple concentrate in a risotto
yes sir come on it's not my menu chef
so this is all you're doing then yeah
[Music]
oh my God can I just have five minutes
on the on my own with the owner would
you mind yeah sure
[Music]
you know how do you expect something
magical when it's coming out of a
[__] can 23 [__] years I wait to
give him [__] apple juice concentrate
I just feel absolutely destroyed my food
is so much better than what I just
[__] gave Gordon
and you know how am I gonna go home and
face my kids when they're all proud of
me and I'm like look at dog car food
you know that's not why I became a chef
[Music]
if you're in the kitchen cooking who's
running the Inn honestly I'm here and
I'm busting my butt trying to get it to
where it should be there's no one
running this scene
that's the problem apart from being
soulless is rudderless there's just a
free-for-all you've checked out no I
haven't why would anyone come and stay
here because it's a nice place in the
country it's like a house of Madness
yeah but it's it starts with you Sandy
everyone's saying the management the
management the management everybody
blaming the managements the Management's
you
foreign
[Music]
the one thing Vermont's fake four
seasons has going for it is its
beautiful Riverside location lovely
what's that building over there a guest
house that's a dog kennel is it used no
the kennel doesn't do anything
radiant heat floor renewable energy with
pellets in the furnace they're Crimson
bare it looks like a prison and what's
through here this is a giant indoor play
area for the dogs play area I wouldn't
put my dog in a place like this what a
waste
but it all looks unused they are geez my
marketing executive sucks I think you're
right
crazy
[Music]
word has gone out that I'm in town so
the Four Season dining room is full of
customers for the first time in months
yeah we are dinner is served I feel
sorry for all of them Sandy honestly I
wouldn't even feed that to a dog or are
you familiar with the area
oh nice with everyone looking after the
restaurant water food get it out of here
I'm tired of waiting and Sandy burying
himself in the kitchen there's no one to
look after the Inn you guys checking in
We Are so the servers are forced to
check in guests in the middle of dinner
service
the room rates 275. get that to you
right now thank you very much no problem
is that normal there Friday night
walking like that you just charge them
275 can you just go and ask the owner
excuse me Sandy yes how much is Friday
walk-in 209 okay because Desiree told me
275 so how come nobody knows we need a
level of consistency across the board
from now on 300 we're taxed it's a joke
I don't think I've been properly trained
at the desk I feel like I'm training
myself don't apologize to them and say
it's 209 there right the in is the
busiest it's been in months but Sandy's
still hiding in the kitchen playing Chef
oh for God's sake upstairs guests are
experiencing the unique charm of the
Four Seasons Inn we don't have any
towels and we found some garbage under
the bed there
please I'm sorry
can't get over the Barking not in the
background barking is unnerving I can't
believe an owner turns such a blind eye
to the problems in his Inn I've got to
stop him hiding behind the stove when
you take two minutes down go have a look
at the dining room check on things do
you have any idea what's going on out
there right now I'm native is right back
here can you handle this line Steve for
30 seconds
any further
is he for real he's an owner not someone
who should be doing what I should be
doing bottom line I've just never seen
this [__] going on before this is
unorganized [__] chaos is what this
is I've got somebody who's got their
fingers on the [__] poles
how was everything
um
and the vegetables were very very hard
how is everything so far
[Music]
being told in the restaurant nothing's
at the level you think it was it's like
getting kicked in the nuts
a failure is wanting to run into the
kitchen and hide
Sunday of Odin's guest is a mad way to
run it in but it's a lack of tie that's
crippling his business I have to
confront it head on let's have five
minutes together in the lounge please
everybody holy Jesus what is about to go
down now
[Music]
that's why there's no standards because
nobody's getting paid so there's no
responsibilities
[Music]
if you pay peanuts you get monkeys if
you pay nothing you get [__] all
zero it's our business it's a [__]
joke
talk to me Sandy honestly Gordon oh well
we started off with other good
intentions and we've had every bump in
the road because when we started out we
started out wonderfully
stop it it's an embarrassment stop the
lies there's no lies if you were not
booming when you first opened air it out
go ahead nobody believes it Sandy
where's your marketing there's nothing
to Market so what have you done
for God's sakes man please
[Music]
exhausted it's been nerve-wracking to
watch this go off in the wrong direction
you can't run a business with no
infrastructure
and you can't have a business
that's got nobody heading it
enough
for one day
I'm gonna pick this up in the morning
show I wish I could say good night
ah truth hurts
I guess I could be one big [__] can I
threat bad Innings
and a disgusting smelly pillow so far my
stay at Vermont's fake four seasons has
been a huge disappointment
the owner doesn't know his ass from his
elbow oh that's a nice the staff don't
get paid
the guests are miserable there's a stain
here next to the bed only later the dog
is happy here I'm hoping a quick dip in
the swimming pool will get my day off to
a better start
does that look like a present from Layla
a floating turd oh my God later
she's in the pool there's no way I'm
going in there how about the hot tub
slightly warm
and Layla hasn't taken a [__] in it
great news
oh
[Music]
my God it's all gorgeous view to the
river
this place has a lot of potential but
only if I can get Sandy to stop hiding
from his guests and the problems here
I'm gonna confront him with his worst
nightmare to wake him up to his
responsibilities as an Innkeeper Wayne
Gordon yes how you doing chef come
upstairs something I want to show you
yeah I'm thinking okay he's going to
show me something wrong maybe the hole
in the wall board by the door
[Music]
good morning good morning no
there's a room full of people I thought
I was gonna pass out
I'm here to help this place I really
need your honest feedback so would you
mind if we start with you there was a
sign that I liked when we came in about
all dogs have to be on your leash and we
had our dog and we come in and it was
immediately a no dog coming out it's not
on a leash you know dogs friendly but it
always takes a few minutes with new
animals sure if I had read that it was
dog friendly
I thought it was really interesting if
there was a dog laying in the dining
room and as much as we like dogs I don't
want a dog in where I'm eating
I agree I think it was disgusting
there's one last person I'd like to
introduce you to Amy Loomis this lady is
the general manager of one of the Hilton
brand hotels and if there's one thing
this lady knows it's how to run a hotel
first impressions
at dinner there was dog hair on the
tablecloth dog hair on the plate that we
were given they asked to speak with the
manager I was told there is no manager
we have an owner I said I'd like to
speak with them then I was told you were
too busy
I've never had the complaints that I had
today it's humiliating it's embarrassing
it's like being flogged in the center of
town
there's something I need to show you all
I need you all to put a pair of these on
please
[Music]
hot and absorbing everything yeah yes
okay
lights off
now this black light shows up bodily
fluids what oh I sit around sir yeah oh
right there
Sandy can you say that yes
yeah I slept on that pillow
charging guests to sleep on such filth
is outrageous the quilt see the splashes
yeah do you know what that is
it begins with s yeah and I'm sorry
yeah disgusting but I want to show you
something over by your feet Sandy come
over here
you see that
oh yeah the carpet
I mean honestly Madam your feet are
right on it yeah look you see that yes
stands on the carpeter I have no idea
that could be a dog that could be a
human if it's a human good Christmas
just when you thought it was safe to
walk in bare feet trust me that has
never ever been clean absolutely
disgusting oh yes yes please take your
glasses off
Chef we have another day to stay here
today and tomorrow
and after seeing the light
I don't want to stay here tonight I
don't want to put my head on that pillow
or any of the other pillows
[Music]
no one would return and the existing
guests that we have want to check out
thank you madam please thank you you're
looking at a room full of customers who
are looking at you saying I can't
believe you put me in there
and that's maddening
and it's embarrassing I need some fresh
air I feel sick
[Applause]
that sucks to know where I am right
right now it's horrified
it does hurt me inside the tears just
keep coming out of my face
it's not what I wanted
I'm mortified
it's been a tough few days that the Four
Seasons in
um do we have another room because I'm
not going to be staying in here the food
is [__] hideous
this black light shows bodily fluids
absolutely disgusting I don't want to
stay here tonight I don't want to put my
head on that pillow the truth has been
hard for Sandy to hear but he's finally
realized the damage that hiding from his
customers has caused now that I've
opened his eyes I've got to figure out a
way to make his business work hello
Leila so that Sandy has no excuses not
to pay his staff
you have so much weight on your
shoulders and you're being totally
oblivious to what your customers need
you cannot run an in if I'm behind a
stove
you're not the head chef You're The
Innkeeper
and that can be a an amazing job that
could be an amazing prospect that can be
an exciting role trust me I am ready I
spend last night time
there's no lie
this was a dream since I was a little
kid this is what I want I love what I do
but I would love to get back to where I
should be as an Innkeeper you have a
potential gold mine here
embrace it
okay yes sir I know it's hard yeah you
it's normal to get upset
but just embarrassed to get qualified
yes head out of my ass and absolutely
start building a dream
we're gonna make this work thank you sir
okay
with Sandy committed to change it's time
to get the crew involved let's go and
have a couple of minutes outside from
the Terrace uh that have some very
important breaking news
this man from this day on is not
the head chef
this man is going to become the Inn
Keeper no longer will he be burying his
head inside the kitchen ignoring issues
he'll be running his end
you are a chef and this is your general
manager
and as a reminder to make sure we step
forward and not backwards
he is not going to be needing these
[__] things say goodbye to Sandy's
chef coats
[Applause]
burn that thing get rid of that thing he
has no business wearing it
you may be a great guy but you are not a
[__] great chef let's get out right
there's a big difference there is Gordon
coming here has opened my eyes to my
shortcomings I love what I do and I need
to start doing it
got it yes sir there are some very big
changes coming tomorrow
embrace them get ready for it
this Inn has been neglected for so long
but now I'm finally giving it the
makeover it truly deserves come on girl
good morning good morning Garden wow
Sandy you look incredible thank you sir
how you doing I feel liberated to be
honest with you you're great ah with
fresh shave new haircut I feel amazing I
feel like a million dollars I feel like
what I spend on my end all right what'd
you guys think of your new Innkeeper
is this
Innkeeper
right when I first arrived I drove into
the Four Seasons Inn but this
establishment is a one-off it's not part
of a chain right so you deserve your own
name your own identity and something
that you can be proud of everybody is
going to know you now as
welcome
[Music]
great rooms fresh food and luxury
candles that is amazing laila's
Riverside Lodge is amazing the names are
some of the sun's beautiful it's just uh
screams me what do you think I think
it's absolutely perfect and represent
something so meaningful to Sandy yeah
absolutely right you okay yeah you sure
are positive yeah what do you think
should we go inside love to
this is the new reception area I have a
look at this
[Music]
[__]
wow so let's welcome our guests in to a
proper Reception Area this is inviting
this is warm I love it breathtaking is
it lovely gorgeous if you have an
inviting Lounge then you need the menu
to go with it gents come through please
I've created a Farm to Table menu of
fresh food that will give people a warm
and friendly Vermont welcome I've
revamped the entire menu let me tell you
about some of my favorites homemade
country Pate I mean look what we are
look at the farm surrounding the Inn I
hope you not have a stunning country
Pate
wonderful poutine done with the braised
pork shoulder stunning chicken pot pie
easy to execute for the kitchen baked
job done and then our stunning Vermont
cheesecake
how are you feeling very hopeful for the
future now are you happier now that
Sandy is out of the kitchen I am
absolutely ecstatic that Sandy is out of
the kitchen the menu is absolutely
perfect
all right now don't be shy
my God
wow that past there's a world of
difference man before when people asked
me where I worked I used to hang my head
and sing The Four Seasons I'm not gonna
do that no more
I can look them right in the eye and say
I work at Layla's
it's gonna be good
I'm delighted they like the new name and
new menu I can't wait to see what they
think of the bedrooms
oh my God
wow gone is That Hideous wallpaper
replace with this stunning wooden
feature
I've steamed the carpet So Gone are
those hideous stains we have a luxury
bed for the dog and what I was more
depressed with than anything was the
linen was hideous
We have replaced the bedding
in every room of your Inn with a hundred
thousand dollars of organic Linens
huh you happy you happy ecstatic that's
really overwhelming
do you want to see another room I've
loved her that's what you're gonna love
room three look at this gone are those
flimsy bunk beds give your guests some
space it's something I would want to
check into I love the new rooms they're
amazing I actually can't wait to clean
them I'm really excited about how
everything came together there's one
more exciting thing I've got to show you
something that I feel can transform this
business
you ready oh yes sir let's go
[Music]
I've just revealed the new improvements
to send these in however there's still
one more surprise I have for him that
will really put Layla's on the map
welcome to the thing that makes your
Lodge unique
a new and improved dog kennel oh my God
amazing I'm stunned
wow we've doubled the size of these
kennels we've made them feel luxurious
we have beautiful brand new bedding when
I first arrived these kennels felt like
a prison now it feels like a reward or a
treat any dog lover want their dogs to
stay even me I'd bring my old dogs here
do you wanna do you want to meet RuPaul
run Pole
hello mate
hello bud
there he is
[Music]
Rob hold me Layla come on hello
hello oh yeah hey look at you who's that
who's that okay
how gorgeous
now this part for me is one of the most
exciting Parts come this way
oh my god I've never seen the kennel
with that many dogs and that many people
that many Smiles
yes you should oh yes the dogs are here
because we've organized their dog
agility competition oh no kidding wow
and all the owners are gonna be checking
in and staying in the Inn this evening
wow
kind of events can be done every month
which will drive dog enthusiasts become
a stay in your stunning Lodge sounds
amazing so we're liven the place up
giving it warmth yes and Sunday this is
Shannon Hagan you may recognize this
ladies yes ideal she is a luxury
boarding kennel consultant she has very
kindly donated to you ten thousand
dollars worth of consultancy that she's
going to help Implement and get this
business off the ground
now let's get back to the end thank you
[Music]
with a delicious new menu and a name of
its own Layla's Riverside Lodge is ready
to open its doors and show off its
stunning new look
ladies guys this is the night that we
come back from the dead we've been
afforded all the tools a great front of
house a great back of house we're going
to make this rock
if we blow this we're we're screwed
good evening and welcome to Layla's my
name is Sandy I'm your Innkeeper hi
follow me I'll take you to your room
thank you here we go
wow the renovated rooms are a big hit
with a new guests can't wait to get
under the sheets
oh yeah she's got a place where she can
just kind of hang out and just you know
be yourself right by the window she can
look at the pool and she's got her own
porch look at that wow this is awesome
dinner's underway just to die for isn't
it and at last Sunday is spending time
with his hotel guests and letting his
chefs do the cooking good evening how
was everything it was great fantastic
tonight is the best night we've had here
it wasn't one complaint there wasn't one
plate with food left on it this is the
difference between last time that we
were here and this time it's just
phenomenally different thank you
well done steak in the oven love the
communication yeah tonight it actually
is like cooking in a real kitchen no
Sandy back there everybody's trained
everybody's on the same page we got
great food everything from scratch 7 16.
concerns good we're good that's what I
want to hear and while Sandy's human
guests are loving the food his canine
guests are finding lots to love as well
so welcome to the new channel wow right
Cherry smells nice you got friends it's
fantastic
you have to be thrilled it's beautiful
I'm on cloud nine I hope to ride this
high for many years to come I mean it's
pretty awesome
this Inn is finally on the right track
so it's time for me to say goodbye all
right well done good job thank you sir
yeah really good job Indeed and uh do
not let him back in this kitchen no sir
Bryce tough one we had our highs and
lows but you are really starting to
grasp yeah one normal surprise
everybody's going on payroll tomorrow
everybody they're all going to have a
paycheck every week ready yes that's
music to my ears I'm pleased to hear it
listen good luck thank you sir
Gordon save my Lodge save my ass save my
life
Sunday's running around like a a new man
he's starting to look and sound like an
Innkeeper and if he keeps us up this
gorgeous Inn
can become an amazing place for a great
weekend
let's go come on come on
come on you can't stay come on
come on I know the room's nice we're
gonna go home come on
you lazy [__] come on we gotta go we
have to go I know it's comfy come on you
young man I'm lazy home sweet home I
know this way cool
good boy
let's go here we go
yes
sometimes you can teach an old dog new
tricks or at least make you take a bath
[Music]
good morning lovers Riverside large
since my visit business at Layla's has
been booming and everyone is sharing in
the in success it's 500 bucks tomorrow
W2 how do you rock okay okay we've got a
great team
and you're part of it my staff builds
the world to me every week you get paid
fantastic
because it's a team effort you've got to
have people that believe in you every
week if you get a paycheck thank you so
thank you thank you Gordon from the
bottom of my heart
herbs it hadn't been for you I would not
be here
that's the truth
[Music]
thank you
and now all the staff are back in Sandy
to make Layla's Riverside Lodge a
success oh we're actually say you take
it for the team brother here we go
finally with something to Market Richard
has taken his sales technique to a whole
new level
oh yeah baby come on Rich let's go have
a look at the side wait come come here
and hold my paw
oh
[Music]
surrounded by the stunning Vineyards of
the Sierra Nevada Foothills is Murphy's
California a picturesque destination for
wine enthusiasts and tourists this
historic town has been home to Murphy's
hotel for over 150 years
the hotel has an illustrious history
presidents and legends have come to stay
in this national landmark Partners Brian
Kevin and Joel bought the business nine
months ago
I own a hotel with my two partners I run
the dining room I'm the dining room
manager Kevin he's our bar manager and
Joel he's our Chef wonderful thank you
but it's no one's job to look after the
hotel it's historic but I think it needs
to be maintenance
the historic rooms I wouldn't even stay
in them and I get a discount that's air
conditioning
behind the historic main building there
are 20 so-called modern bedrooms
[Music]
these are modern
I was like it too
[Music]
sadly the owners are too busy drinking
in the bar to notice the state of the
hotel oh man owning a bar at 32 years
old can be just a great party seven days
a week give them some time ready
ladies out doing tonight
Kevin and I we love women and it is a
passion and we have a lot of them coming
through here don't act like you've never
done it
they're not just all young we got the
cougar Clans coming through here we're
not one to discriminate we take customer
service to the next level
is it a California American male we were
taught during college that uh it's good
binge drinking is fun
why is everybody empty I am the fun
Captain she tried Roofing me you see
that I am kind of The Party Guy I want
to make everyone have fun
right now they're just kind of drunk
idiots if you're after a drunken lap
dance you've come to the right place if
you want a good night's sleep you best
go elsewhere I'm exhausted and I keep
hearing these loud noises outside these
people are drunk and it's driving me
crazy I'm gonna go complain
what can I do for you I have a room
upstairs sure
the saloon is always first and then the
hotel just seems like an afterthought
this registered national landmark has
been run ragged by the owners and is
hemorrhaging money if the guys continue
to party and not take things seriously
the hotel's just going to close down if
I don't do something fast this place
won't last another 150 days let alone
years I think Gordon is going to say
[__] this place is they're screwed
[Music]
I'm on my way to Murphy's in Northern
California now this place isn't among
some of the most stunning Vineyards
anywhere in the world
what a beautiful Town look how busy this
place is as well Melissa with stunning
little tasting rooms now anyone lucky
enough to be running a small hotel here
should be sold out every night
are not they must be doing something
seriously wrong
[Music]
it really is historic Murphy's totality
placed in the National register of
historic places nice wow hello how are
you I'm good how are you doing so first
name is Kennetha is it always that busy
out there and we usually do get pretty
busy on the weekends incredible we have
about 16 tasting rooms just within
walking distance of the hotel I love how
historic this place is but have you not
updated the furniture since 1850
let's see how my God it's like going to
your grandma's funeral oh my God they're
there is a difference between historic
and then tacky and old
old me Tacky looks like someone's died
in those chairs
so you've been here for a long time
about a year and a half and what's wrong
with the place
um well management the owners
hi three guys they're in their early 30s
there's Kevin Joel and Brian and they
really like to use the hotels their
playground
um partying drinking giving lap dances
to the bar patrons
so uh there's lap dance lap dances while
they're bartending
the owners that they continue partying
and giving lap dances in the bar and
acting how they've been the place is
just going to keep going downhill
we put you in the presidential Ulysses S
Grant room
this is the actual bed that President
Grant slept in except for the mattress
we did get rid of that what's the glass
box for um this is our display room
display room yes so guests and customers
can come up and take a look
when were these last um replaced
um
I can't really tell you that uh it
sounds like I'm in a museum so my guest
or an example you're a guest
today
come on through everybody
close the door close the door okay we're
gonna be on display today it's usual for
the tourists to come through sometimes
and if a guest checks in and they just
for some reason forget to close their
door they're gonna have people crowded
around looking at them they literally
come over and they hello
hi
well that's embarrassing it's like a
goldfish Bowl in here ladies thank God I
wasn't in my Underpants
isn't that normal they just come and
have a look around
um yeah you know um we normally get
complaints and there's really no one
that handles that or takes care of it
but there's three owners yes a lot of
the time they're busy bartending or
drinking or lap dancing exactly
unfortunately
okay I'm gonna unpack can this uh room
be off the tour for a while we'll see
what we can do thank you you're welcome
First Impressions I mean it may be
steeped in history but this smells like
the room steeped in pissed
we put you in the presidential Ulysses S
Grant room I've just arrived at Murphy's
hotel near Sacramento California it's
like I'm in a museum we're going to be
on display today hello thank God I was
in my Underpants
time for a bite to eat I hope the food
here is less stale than my bedroom
oh he looks so happy bunny oh hello how
are you how do you won party or once not
party for one uh good to see you I'm
Brian is that the same
congratulations Employee of the Month
um did you get a bonus to get a nice day
free dinner I'm one of the only
employees that never made the cut yet I
see you just put yourself in and what
are the owners going to say about that
I'm one of them
I'm Brian stop it yes come on hey the
other owners out there shot on there
you're the owner and you made yourself
Employee of the Month yeah
are you the man with the g-string the G
string reception tell me do you do lap
dancing oh no that would probably be
Kevin RC I don't know my Booty's a
little too big to do the Last Dance okay
I was gonna say I can't wait to see that
one I would love to meet the other two
the chef and the lap dance are they
around I think you want to bring them
out yeah all right Kevin and Joel and I
we're all equal shareholders in this
business but it was my plan to buy the
hotel hello Kevin Kevin come on good to
see you back and this is hi Gordon Joel
Joel so you're the lap dancer
maybe once in a while but okay fine I'm
a wild one when I started drinking I
gave a little strippered action going on
or I need a little Rowdy and can be the
most fun at any young adult could ever
dream of
it's obviously the chef yes restaurant
manager
I'm a lap dancer my manager bar manager
so who's in charge
all three of us
no such thing
so who runs the hotel who's in charge of
the the hotel hotel manager job doesn't
really entail much
the three owners normally there's one
that takes the reins and two other
silent none of you sound and look like
an owner
what Gordon thinks we don't look like
owners but what what's an owner look
like we bought the hotel nine months ago
right and you guys go back a long way
just kind of met each other 15 years ago
and I'm confused whether it's the Three
Musketeers or three stooges
anyway I'm gonna have a quick bite to
eat it's been a long journey I'm excited
to taste the food thank you nice to meet
you thank you Gordon's gonna love our
food Joel works really hard at
everything he puts out everything that
comes out the window is a great product
I can't believe this hotel is owned by
three guys with a pink dining room
Pink's new black well it's like a girl's
bedroom
[Music]
any specials on today we had a fresh
Alaskan halibut with uh
now that I'm talking to you I've
completely forgot no we had we had the
Halibut with a
well this is the first time I forget
specials don't worry why don't you check
with the chef all right I will you have
a Russian measure right yes and I was a
server too Russian manager employ the
mum and owner yes all the above employee
of the month I'm gonna take that plaque
back I can't even remember the specials
Hey Joe I forgot the special just now
Ryan just kind of Forgotten specials I
have seen him do that before the
specials available tonight the
macadamian encrusted halibut right let's
try this guy entrees lamb shank and then
what's the color my door what does door
mean it's a doorway it's just a calamari
steak I I'll go for that as well okay
thank you I'll keep all the menu thank
you very much you're welcome once Gordon
has a bite of Jules food order in he's
gonna put a smile on his face guaranteed
[Music]
in a red wine garlic sauce red wine
garlic
wow
absolutely rancid come a little taste
I mean
nothing's hot uh yeah strange taste you
know that's the first actually the first
time in the history that I've eaten the
escargot already and I'm going to say
that I I don't like it in any way no the
escargot tasted like a dirty funky it's
disgusting flip-flop if you sauteed a
flip-flop I think that would be a good
good way of describing it that was
[__] disgusting
I I want to run home and get some
mouthwash for sure but I don't know do
whatever you need to all right yeah
because I stink
some rice water for you okay please
have any um little samples of like wine
flights anything Regional we've talked
about that but we've not implemented it
so you've been talking about it for nine
months but you haven't actually done it
yet no one's even
bothered the sort of wine flight so
trying to get it together so you've got
this place almost a year and you haven't
implemented something that this town
thrives on correct right
if you taste there's a skunk I mean yes
not really have you eaten I mean you eat
here right very often when was the last
time you guys sat down and had dinner in
the restaurant never have sat down with
all three of us together strange
stranger I'm getting slightly nervous
that nothing actually gets done here
anyway I'm living in hope I have some
more bread for sure
lampshade coming right out right
oh my God
[Music]
holy crap what is that this is our lamb
shank that's a weird looking lamb shank
visually it looks like the biggest plate
of puke I've never personally had lamb
shank ever been here I do not like lamb
are you the Russian manager you don't
like lamb don't eat the scars yeah I'm
the restaurant manager but I'm not I'm
not the chef wow I think I would just
call that a dog's dinner what a mess
I do apologize again
I'm totally embarrassed that our food is
this quality I've always thought it was
better
hey Joel yes the lamb shank he mentioned
that the vegetable gravy goo was a
little little too much oh okay I'm gonna
run this out okay
fine dining Frozen and edible nasty
extra money I mean I'm amazed what's
this one this is the calamari Dore steak
that's not garlic in there again is it
there is garlic in there again geez it's
just how that dish is prepared
everything's just laced with garlic
please
be my guests
what is it trying to be a sponge
[Music]
damn embarrassed I'm chewing on it going
I just want to spit this [__] out right
now like this is terrible so that's the
first bite I've ever taken of that you
know this stuff's on the menu right
you're aware of it this is your hotel
yes yes it's not being punked here that
you guys are their owners we are the
owners we always have them send their
sons in to take the hit no no you
definitely are the owner this is us okay
how do these three stooges qualify to
run
an Historic Hotel like this
if they can't even get the food and wine
right how are they going to improve the
hotel I feel like I'm being looked after
by college kids and they want me to come
out probably be good yeah come on out
sorry I'm very impressed uh no I mean
far from impressed have you ever
actually stood back and looked at that
lamb shank as a dish and it's most
horrendous the most drabby disgusting
looking [__] lamb shank
have you given up no no no way we just
started we're not giving up here you
just started yeah
ever just walked in from outside checked
in went up to the rooms and you've never
done that have you ever done that have
you ever done that I have not oh my god
what have you improved on says you
bought it truthfully and make people
laugh and smile every day seriously what
have you changed weekends we serve
breakfast all day what have you changed
menu wise manual
um [__] hell
I got one two three
idiots that haven't changed anything
[Music]
you don't stay here you don't eat
together you don't criticize the food
[__] reception
[__] room [__] food and three clueless
owners
owners my [__] ass
[Music]
I'm staying at Murphy's hotel in
Northern California and after being put
on display for gorking tourists
and eating an atrocious lunch I think I
would just call that a dog's dinner what
a mess I need to see the three nitwood
owners in action
word has got out that I'm in Murphy's
and the hotel and restaurant are full of
people I feel sorry for all of them
Kevin is getting busy in the bar and
Brian is overseeing the dining room
it should be gear nice gear cheese yeah
isn't it the air cheese
I mean
so guess trying to check in are left to
fend for themselves
is uh everything okay uh yeah we're
waiting we went up to the front desk and
there's nobody there so I'm trying to
check in for the uh it's one of the
artists if I I guess I just arrived to
check in you get Brian urgently or Kevin
what about it about I guess checking in
oh yes check-in would you please I'm
sorry excuse me you shouldn't have to
come looking for us in the bath
so that's what happens when guests come
in late they go to the bar looking for
yes that is uh how are you doing have
you ever done that checked in and then
found the reception clothes and went
into the bath a little quickie no no
I've actually only stayed at hotels
probably only a matter of 20 times in my
entire life on University alone yeah so
how come you guys have anybody up here
we got the bartenders or servers like me
sometimes taking care of it
once guests get to the rooms they're in
for another unpleasant surprise
[Music]
let's wait for the drunkards to go home
before we open that up
[Applause]
a good night it's very noisy in there
from the bar in the Stream
the owner's ignorance is evident in
everything I've seen so far I'm curious
to see what it's like in the parts I
haven't seen like the walk-in fridge
[Music]
that is
pork
cooked [__] disgusting I wish I'd
seen this before I had my lunch fine
dining it's not because [__] the mold
going on there
bloody hell there's moral at the sides
too
oh Jesus Christ look at the [__] mold
on that this is absolutely disgusting
thank you
follow us
so the walk-in how often is that fridge
cleaned out
twice a week yes
everything out yes yeah yes come with me
all of you all right especially the
owners sounds good sounds good really
[__] now
oh wow oh wow
oh wow
look at moldy tortillas there should not
be [__] any moldy [__] food it's
[__] horrible when was this made last
Saturday no I needed to go I smell that
need to toss it I know that
I'm this terrible you should be [__]
ashamed
okay no it's not okay what is that black
mold what's it supposed to be Thai Chili
marinade Thai Chili marinade I don't
know if it's been used in a while the
sauces was from a chef that had been
there like in 2006 or seven or something
exactly the same way as you run this
[__] hotel
you don't give a [__]
I give you [__] I give a [__] and this
is your dream of running a hotel now
about Manning up and look like [__]
owners we are this is [__]
unacceptable and it's not gonna happen
anymore have you checked out because you
should do Your Own Thing say to these
two [__] it he has not checked out he
doesn't talk I have not checked out and
I obviously I need to pay more attention
and do better at my job how many of you
can run a [__] business do you ever
see three CEOs three [__] general
managers no three [__] executive
chefs ah
I'm done
since my arrival at Murphy's hotel in
Northern California you should be
[__] ashamed I've been appalled by
the three clueless owners
are you guys really the [__] owners
true story
[__] off
[Music]
unbelievable I mean three young idiots
that are playing at running a hotel and
not one of them with a [__] clue
tomorrow
I'm at it Joel I'm a [__] owner I
don't [__] want to clean I've been
here 12 hours it's unacceptable
I do want to prove Gordon Ramsay wrong
about me being a [__] idiot [__]
dumb and dumber [__] scoundrel wanker
[__] whatever British [__]
terminology that [__] wanker has to
say across from the [__] different
bomb guy but I do respect him time to
get a drink
I'm gonna go play poker in Reno later
tonight because I'm not going to sleep
listen to the [__] music
how on Earth is anyone gonna ever get to
sleep in this hotel Jesus Christ
that's crazy you know what
frogs asses for everyone in this build
right here right now
[Applause]
how annoying is this doesn't make sense
[Music]
[Applause]
it's got to be a quieter room somewhere
you surely divorce
[Music]
[Applause]
you got it
[Music]
[Applause]
One Nation [__]
[Music]
please oh [__] here we go
hey I I have a walk-in to clean I've
been here I want to go get that cleaning
because it's number one right now
this is a joke
just a joke third partying and I'm upset
and uh we're just I don't know they're
partying
they wanted to see it and uh I was upset
earlier and I'm upset and Joel I'm
upsetted everything that's going on and
I want this is I'm just upset about how
about thank you for two minutes about
your guests I want to go I'm gonna go
for you I'm gonna go clean the walking
just walk off like that you know what
I'm gonna go clean the walking because
you know why why you acting like a
[__] joke because I'm I'm upset that
was [__] unacceptable there's
unacceptable the [__] walking with
the [__] black mold so why don't you
do something about it I I was I if I if
not everyone
all right
I'm gonna clean the water they just walk
off like that okay
you know why why acting like a [__]
joke Brian is coming undone and is
drinking on the job I'm done trying to
get through to him today I'm upset I was
[__] unacceptable on there it's
unacceptable okay
go home all right
I'm gonna do it in a t-shirt Jesus
Christ I've been told the hotel offers
modern rooms further from the bar so
I've asked to be putting one so I can
get away from all this madness
[Music]
and they call these modern rooms it
looks like my grandma's house from the
1950s look at this wallpaper hideous and
what sort of hotel is this when you
can't
[Applause]
this is supposed to be quieter down here
[Music]
what an awful nice sleep
play stinks man come on the moon my ass
this place is such a mess from the awful
Decor to the Dreadful food to the
drunken partying all night long
I need to get the whole team together
and find out how it's gotten into this
state good morning guys good morning
it's uh go downstairs have a meeting
feels good yeah with a team cool
[Music]
[Applause]
man that was a bad night's sleep the
noise above here was insane I came back
downstairs last night and Brian's
ripping his shirt up shouting screaming
about hey shots all on me is that normal
is that really how these managers
operate when they're off duty they come
behind the bar turn up the Jukebox when
I've already turned it down pour
themselves drinks it's their personal
frat house
how does that make you feel your
employees are concerned that you're
drunk in the bath when do I treat you
all [__] badly
what yeah when it comes to scheduling
how many days that you guys have asked
off four that you didn't get off it's
not what I'm asking if you're gonna run
a hotel it's not about having a [__]
party it's about levels of discipline
well just so you know it's not happening
anymore but I'm not going to be as happy
sometimes for you guys
you are as good as your team they
represent you and based on what I've
seen I don't think you represent them
properly okay if you go first and tell
these owners what they need to hear we
lose a lot of reservations when we don't
have somebody to answer the phone you
know when we leave the front desk we put
the phone in the bar after 8 PM we are
the front desk we are the bartenders I
saw that last night yeah they don't
answer the phone because they don't hear
it
we need online booking you know what
that takes away online bookings as front
desk girls you know we've talked about
getting rid of the front desk and
putting a computer there and we don't
have a person there self-checking so how
do you feel about that so they can play
and you threatened to fire them yeah no
that's not what it is yes it is yes it
is you just totally attacked me I'm
afraid to express my feelings I'm afraid
I'm gonna get fired ready nobody's
threatened here with their job nobody
has you never threatened me by being
fired I have before were you drunk yes
you were drunk
that's the message I'm trying to get
through to your fake skulls your
threatening staff whilst inebriated this
is crazy people who deserve to be fired
are these three standing here there's no
structure
somebody needs to step up and run the
business and everybody else follows
suits you need one general manager
that's
that's you need to be a leader from the
top that's one person there can be 25
owners but there needs to be one general
manager if something doesn't change you
guys are gonna lose this place
okay which one of you is capable of
stepping up and running this business
I'm at Murphy's hotel in Northern
California you're the owner and you made
yourself Employee of the Month yeah the
place is a mess because these three
owners behave like Frat Boys cheers
and none of them is a leader you've
checked out so the staff don't know
which way to turn I'm afraid to express
my feelings I'm afraid I'm gonna get
fired
I've got to change
there needs to be one general manager
somebody needs to take charge
[Music]
and take charge I'm in a random business
I'm our leader anniversary it's going to
be me guaranteed if you're gonna run the
hotel you gotta you run the hotel yeah
100 so Kevin and Joel are you willing to
give him the support and the autonomy to
actually run this place
yes yes
Brian it's your responsibility now to
General manage an absolutely toe the
line but there are three rules rule
number one to stop drinking on the floor
rule number two they have to stop
working the floor yeah and rule number
three you have to [__] grow some fast
Brian does know the most out of the
three of them so I really do think if he
could stop his party in ways he could
really do it trust me if you don't grow
up now you never will I got it it's a
hotel not a frat house I'm not going to
be drinking and uh I'm gonna be owner
thank God for that
thank you thank you I'm going to change
I'm going to be more of an owner and not
a friend slash co-worker and they're
going to see a different Brian
the future of this historic national
landmark is now in Brian's hands and I
need to know that he cares enough to be
responsible you are young ambitious
slightly naive you're going at it in
totally the wrong way you're on the
verge of losing this business hopefully
not and how would you feel if you lost
the business it would be horrible it'd
be horrible because that's already years
of uh 60-hour weeks it's horrible
I'm here to help
but I wouldn't understand the mess
you're in it's not good all right
do you understand I do I think down
inside there's no two ways better you're
a fun guy I've got a lot to offer yeah I
just stop being irresponsible ever I
just man up yeah for sure you can do it
okay I want to make this work
um
from today on it's going to be a change
business is different all right okay
I could see that small back in your face
thank you I'll see you later from this
day forward I'm a change man and the
business is going to reflect all those
changes
with Brian ready to take charge as
general manager my design team has
worked all night to modernize Murphy's
hotel and now it's time to reveal the
new look hotel to Brian and his team
Brian how are you sir Gordon good how
are you doing we're very smart are you
good you're doing I'm good good my
ladies how are we okay
right welcome everyone the new and
improved Murphy's Historic Hotel are you
ready ready
is awesome exactly how it should be
when I first walked in I was
disappointed it was just like I began to
climax now you have a nice warm oh
modern feel the minute you walk in oh
your guests will arrive and feel
welcomed yeah take a seat there's the
beautiful yes amazing beautiful amazing
Brian what do you think beautiful
absolutely beautiful welcoming
perfect what Gordon has done with the
lobby is beautiful now that blue it's so
warm it's so welcoming it's awesome this
is a Historic Hotel your ex-president
stayed here yes that doesn't happen that
often in hotels
there's more there's more from six
o'clock this morning you're now live
with online bookings
[Applause]
you don't go anywhere near the bar you
know what time they're coming and you
are now in the 21st century are you
ready to see the presidential suite yeah
yeah all right
come and see my room let's go
I think you'll love it let's go jump in
oh my God that is awesome
this one's been freshened up this one's
been spruced up you need that Vibrance
the minute you walk into a room you want
to feel wow I'm stepping into history
but I also want some comfort this is fit
for a president our president now could
stay here Obama would be okay to stay
here now it still feels historic but
it's a bedroom not a museum yeah exactly
so you know make sure that when your
guests are checked in their bedrooms are
off the tour did you put a new robes is
there something on here this will be
lined and cushions
for me the big problem wasn't the Linens
it was the noise we've come up with a
solution to narrow that down last time
it's midnight well stick to those times
of your bar closing because the damage
you can do to your reputation is
devastating yep we're gonna follow
through and make sure that our customers
in the hotel are as happy as our
customers in the bar and our customers
in the restaurant
so you already see the rooms outside
that you told me were modern right
let me show you what modern is you ready
yeah
you can see why I got upset Leona's done
nothing in nine months so we've done all
this in [__] 24 hours
I'm blown away I can't believe the the
creativity that's been put into this
place in the last few days John what do
you think
um Last Words inspired you know very
inspiring you know they said you should
never ever ever be afraid of change
you've got to keep on going oh yeah
every time Brian what do you think
what's going through your mind I've
never heard you so quiet breathtaking no
I don't even know what to say because
it's beautiful it's just something
beautiful this is perfect with this kick
in the ass we're gonna go forward Full
Throttle we're gonna make changes that
no one's ever seen before you ready to
see the dining room yes
the dining room
beautiful where's the pink oh my God
yeah are those horrendous pink walls a
stunning beautiful color on the walls
that just pop and there's one more thing
this bit you're gonna love it's a
surprise that's gonna completely change
your business you ready for this
[Applause]
[Music]
I've just revealed the stunning new
improvements to the historic Murphy's
Hotel
our president now could stay here and
now there's one more addition that will
ensure this hotel thrives in the future
you are in the heart of some of the most
sought after wineries anywhere in the
world and it's a massive Market that you
have been missing out on and here's why
every famous Winery has a lovely Tasting
Room on this Main Street at five o'clock
they close here you're not going to pick
up that business this is a menu designed
to pair with great local wines oh wow
okay this is incredible oh my gosh start
off with that lovely cheese plate the
chicken of a crocini paired with a
stunning chilled Rose and then this
wonderful local local ricotta dip you
now have a perfect menu when those
tasting rooms close at five o'clock you
pick it up and you continue it and where
they're gonna stay the night yeah yeah
that's right after dinner I want you to
dig in and Sample the Wayne TC menu is
awesome the overall experience to any
guest that walks through our door now I
believe is gonna be better than ever I
like the pairing of the bruschetta and
the wine that it goes a very nice fresh
dish there's no going back no it's only
going up now yeah
oh that's nice oh this is so phenomenal
this is gonna put us on the map
off the charts reservations off the hook
thank you Chef thank you as well as a
wine pairing menu I've changed the
entire menu in the dining room let me
show you one of my favorite dishes I'm
very excited about the new menus I know
where I'm eating every night oh my God
fresh baked lemon meringue pie oh my
goodness look at that thing the real
inspiration behind this was Brian's hair
[Applause]
is going to touch a business a clientele
that we've never had at the Murphy's
hotel and I know personally I can't wait
to eat there more often
with warm and fresh rooms and the new
wine tasting menu my only concern is
whether Brian can stay focused on the
guest experience I listen every night
from now on in this hotel is a big night
let me tell you and it's not just about
the past but the restaurants and the
rooms push those tasting menus in that
bar GM are you ready we're ready um if
there's one thing you do not need as a
general manager as an apron get that off
all right
good luck guys
[Applause]
hello how are you doing good how are you
with extended front desk operating hours
guests can easily check in and feel
welcome in the new Lobby
[Music]
it's nice I'll bet it would be a
comfortable sleep I know it's going to
be fun and they're enjoying the
renovated and peaceful rooms
this is the Newsome Harlow and the wine
tasting menu is a hit that looks lovely
guys they're loving the food keep it
going yeah well done and good luck
when I first arrived you saw three young
guys sort of playing at running a bar
and completely forgetting that they were
actually in charge of a hotel but Brian
stepped up and has taken that general
manager role which is great news I'm
hoping now that they get that party mode
out of their mind and focus on the
potential of what this business can
bring them
great job
um you performed like owners tonight you
sound like owners and this place you
know is rocking the atmosphere in the
bar is controlled the dining room's
having fun the patio is full the wine
tasting menu is flying out keeping the
good work okay Gordon he really has
opened my eyes and showed me that we
need to take more of a leadership role
as an owner I'll take you out of the
employee of the month I know choose one
together yes on a monthly basis have
your input yeah throw it into the pot I
believe Gordon has saved his place by
putting wind in our sails again we truly
did need a kick in the ass because we
were playing around a little too much
actions speak louder in your next day
you'll hear great things I guarantee
Gordon is amazing he's a magician and I
think that he came through and he
transformed the hotel into this
wonderful Masterpiece and I'm so
thankful that he came through and helped
us what a gorgeous place
I never did get to see Kevin Love dance
since my visit to the historic Murphy's
Hotel the owners have finally become
owners Joel is keeping the kitchen and
the walking extra clean and he has new
pride in his work I got a well done
going right there you can go peek at the
upstairs bathrooms one's down the hall
showers both restrooms upstairs yeah you
stay there I'm good right here Brian is
stepping up as general manager focusing
his efforts on the hotel Brian is
definitely capable of being the general
manager Gordon has completely changed
everything
Gordon brought the Historic Hotel back
to life
[Music]